ouverture à metz du procès du meurtrier
présumé de deux garçons âgés de 8 ans le
procès de patrick s'est ouvert à huis
clos devant la cour décide in le jeune
homme avait 16 ans au moment des faits
arrêté sept mois plus tard il avait
avoué avant de se rétracter à metz un
vague bâtir
en début d'audience nous n'avons pu
apercevoir qu un jeune homme masse balle
le chevron s'asseoir dans le box des
accusés
à quelques mètres de lui les pièces à
conviction deux vélos de cross avec
lesquelles s'amuser les enfants le jour
du meurtre ainsi que cinq grosses
pierres les armes du crime ensuite la
porte du palais de justice s'est refermé
sur un procès qui débute deux ans après
l'arrestation de patrick deux années
pendant lesquelles il a souvent changé
d'avis dans un premier temps il avoue le
double meurtre et donne plusieurs
détails édifiant puis ensuite se
rétracte estimant avoir craqué devant
les policiers aujourd'hui lorsqu'on le
questionne sur ses premiers aveux il
reste silencieux ne donne aucune
explication sur les fameux détails
aujourd'hui et nous espèrons commencé à
faire part de leurs conclusions suivront
ensuite 40 témoins puis le rapport des
policiers qui ont recueilli les premiers
aveux de patrick un moment qui sera
certainement l'un des points forts de ce
procès prévu en principe sur quatre
jours